all right baby get that hitter this
episode brought to you by great block
pizza and great block is a you know you
know what it is I mean it's like
sometimes you you're laying in bed at
night and you wish you had something
inside of you you wish you had something
deep inside of your body just you know
either maybe going in and out of your
body even just staying in your body and
if it's something that you wish was
staying in your body then that something
is great block pizza that's food in
great block pizza and you can find it on
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach get that hitter today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet and you
know what it is it's a special type of
wallet
so many people have a wallet and they
don't they can't find it Oh where's my
wallet Daniel and Daniel's like I don't
know you know I but you know I had a
couple snow cones and - you know I've
been doing nothing well where's my
wallet and you can't find your wallet
because who knows why maybe you lost it
well with the ridge wallet you're less
likely to lose it because you keep it in
your front pocket you know what's that
front pocket carry you know a back
pocket you got to pull that thing out
every time you sit down you got a you
got a deal UMP your cheeks you know you
got a um you got a unhung your derriere
by pulling out that rear that rear that
rear carry but with the ridge wallet you
got that front pocket carry it's concise
it potentially bulletproof now that's up
to you no guarantees but the ridge
wallet check it out ridge wallet comm
slash Theo th e Oh for a beautiful
discount and now that is a prayer it's a
kind of a pricey item but that's okay
some people want a pricey item and I
bought mine actually they gave it to me
be honest with you and I loved it and I
really really I really do enjoy oh yeah
I am happy that you guys are here today
and I am happy that I am here today and
uh and that's it let's see yeah let's
see how it all shakes out she's got
that burlock shot of whiskey she's been
known to bring a man to his knees mr.
power of a woman she'll take all you
have you never see your common and
that's how I know the devil has Obama
[Music]
will mr. Johnson news cuz it's not her
opposed in the Delta
man if you don't mind would you tune
this guitar for me man
[Music]
that's how I know the devil is a woman
messing awkward in and out there for
that song by me but you know that the
truth is you know you know I want things
to run smoothly you know that song is
kind of that song is kind of tapering
right there and I'm thinking man oh you
know I want to smoothly kind of ease out
of the song into the episode but that
ain't the way [ __ ] happens man that
ain't the way it happens you know like
in all the commercials you see the man
he you know he crack open that condom
package you know when he just splits
open that condom package and he you know
he gets that condom and he just you know
just magically just it just surfs down
onto his dick real quick you know it
just surfs right onto his wiener and
suddenly he's everything's okay and he's
cruising him and he's you know and he's
doing full sexual and and the lady's
happy and nobody that ain't the way it
happens
no the way it happens is your first of
all you lie and say you don't have any
condoms then the girl says no you have
to have some condoms then you like say I
think I have one you know and you go
look for it it's probably in your car or
it's you know you might have hid it in a
vase or something if you you know we're
trying to hide some condoms from
somebody you know and you didn't have
any flowers in the house at that time
and you you know you put it into an open
vase but you you know you go look
forward and then you bring it in there
and by then now your your erection is
gone I mean you know what I'm saying I
got that ghost [ __ ] boy you don't say oh
my [ __ ] shows up real quick and it's
looking a [ __ ]
and then it's gone and it's there and
gone I got that ghost cop like blue and
it's gone so then you get back with that
condom package and now you got to crack
that thing open you know you got it on
and now it's a you know now you're
working this softy it's like gum you
know you're working this softy inside of
it's almost like you're making sausage a
little bit more like and now you got to
try to have sex and everybody's
disappointed and it's just I don't know
but that's just you know things don't
know that it's not always exactly how we
want it to go you know the thing things
in the in life aren't always gonna be
just served up like we want them to you
know you know you think about your
future and you you know especially when
you're a kid and you think about it so
many ways and you know when I was young
I used to think about I guess my big
thing that I wanted when I was young
that rich people seem to have porches
they had a porch on their house and you
see somebody with that big porch and a
porch it was like oh you got outside
yeah oh you got inside but you got it
outside
like damn you must be doing well if you
have an inside that is outside and if
you saw somebody with a porch and
sometimes they had furniture out there
you know and telev it you know you'd
even see like during a party something
to put a television out there and watch
the games and man and when I was yelling
that was my big thing I pictured like a
porch you know and I pictured a wife and
I would have a wife you know or it could
have been a husband with long hair but I
think you know my visions weren't super
clear but it seems like a wife you know
but then you never know sometimes a man
might be hiding in a wig even sometimes
in your imagination and and my wife and
I would be sitting on the front porch
and we would just be like sitting on the
swing set together and just sitting
there and being like proud of ourselves
that we you know that we hadn't given up
on each other and that we we were doing
okay you know
about that porch I guess maybe the porch
you know implies or an amplifier might
not be a word and that's okay that's
okay and it is now suddenly a really
really you get what it means and but it
implies like that we were proud of
ourselves a little bit the porch I think
because you you would do it outside you
know cuz I remember when I was young it
was like like uh you know every you
always try to hide [ __ ] inside and put
when you're grow up in a poor
environment and look I'm not whining
about it but when you grow up in a poor
environment you don't have distance like
money give money gives you distance you
know money put you in first-class
seating on the air jet so you have
distance from people you know money uh
it'll make you you have a yard right a
front yard sometimes money you have a
front yard and then your front yard has
a front yard you ever seen that somebody
has a front yard with a big gate then in
front of the gate a little more yard
your [ __ ] gate has a yard but money
gives you distance and when you grow up
without money you don't have that so
everything's just stacked right on top
of each other it's all right there it's
all you know it's all immediate and it's
all it's just all it's all right there
for viewing and for smelling and for
feeling and so like we would always try
to the only way you could kind of hide
stuff was inside cuz outside there
wasn't any you know you didn't have a
porch she didn't have a yoke like if
somebody if you got your ass beat
outside dude it happened in front of all
your neighbors and if you know if she
got too loud inside the windows were
open because the air conditioning wasn't
on until nighttime so you know it was
just you know everything was just out in
the open more and you knew more about
each other and there was some stuff like
that it made you feel I guess a little
bit more ashamed but then in another way
it made you feel more connected but I
guess in my vision in my dream you know
I have this I have this space where you
know or when I was young and I would
think about the future I would think
about having this porch and sitting out
there with my wife and we wouldn't be
yelling you know we would just be kind
of relaxed and maybe sharing like a
lemonade or something I don't want to
sit out throw my own
if it's some you know I think you got to
share a lemonade cuz you don't want to
be too you know too high on the hog
everybody's sitting up there with their
own lemonade you know what are you that
I am princess Sheba so but that would be
a vision I would have when I was young
and I don't even know how I got on that
right now but that would be a vision
that I had when I was young of a future
that I wanted you know but you don't
know how it's you don't know what's
gonna happen and it doesn't always shake
out the way that you wanted to and you
have to roll with the punches and life
is just a [ __ ] surprise party it's a
surprise party dude and you don't even
know who it's for and you don't know how
old anybody is or what's going on and
but you just people just keep yelling
surprise and [ __ ] keeps happening and
that is um and that's life I guess
that's just time you know every second
is just surprise surprise surprise and
there you go and you keep going and some
of the surprises are for you and some of
them are for other people you know and
it's just you got to just you got to
recognize sometimes they're not for you
and you have to enjoy them when they're
for other people as well I think or try
to it's really hard that song on the way
in right there that was devil as a woman
by Bishop Gunn and I want to try to and
play some other songs on the podcast
instead of just Bishop Gunn and I will
but I have not had enough time to listen
through all the music that's been
submitted but I thank you guys for your
submissions thank you guys for coming
out in Oxnard this weekend dude Oxnard
that place whoo that's middle of
nowheres boy I mean it's not really it's
like Los Angeles adjacent you know it's
kind of like it seemed like a lot of men
maybe sin there you know if they got a
lot of sidepiece it seems like the
sidepiece belt a lot of men send their
side pieces to live out there in Oxnard
you know you see a lady out there and
panties and heels just to you know water
and a plant you're like what but she
lives by herself but she's outside you
know and she's live streaming footage
back to Los Angeles to her man who's
probably sitting in a house with his
family you know pretending like he's
reading the paper but he low-key has a
Kindle right there a Kindle that gets
video Amazon Kindle Fire
I think and it gets video and so he's
low-key you know he's watching that TNA
spraying agua on the vegetal us out
there in Oxnard and meanwhile he's
sitting there with his family looking at
a newspaper but that's all who knows
that's all whatever but oxen always good
men a lot of people came out you know I
want to apologize for every that came
out a Friday Late Show they had a lot
you know they had a co unruly people in
the crowd and the the management at the
club was gutter you know or the
organization at the club was gutter
you know they had people in and out of
the groom that I'm in the places of [ __ ]
in damn bro you know I'm saying seem
like a pet shop that's what it seemed
like but the people that came out were
great and I'm super grateful for
everybody that came and we had fun man
we had a good time that a young fella
brought me out this shirt this kind of
like I don't know if it's like a farmer
shirt or what it is but if I ever get a
farm I'll definitely put that thing on
[ __ ] if I even even just you know if I
even walk up on a couple of you know a
couple of you know a couple of
strawberry plants or anything even just
a you know a peach tree I'll put that
[ __ ] on I don't really have to have a
whole farm
oh what a week man I had AI had just
such a wild week you know the World Cup
was on and do not been watching this
thing and you know what my first uh if
your country is still any of your teams
in it that's awesome you know I really
liked watchin Brazil because Brazil did
watch um Brazil play soccer it's like
it's like for me anyway it seemed like
they speak a different language with
their feet you know what like a lot of
the other countries we speak this kind
of this you know this sort of America
just kind of stutters with our feet when
it comes to soccer but Brazil it's like
watching ballerinas
you know everybody's out there Billy
Elliot and you know it's like capoeira
and there happens to be a ball on the
field it's just it's just remarkable
it's remarkable to watch and and so I
you know I enjoyed watching them I
enjoyed watching Japan you know I
thought Japan could go a little bit
farther and just the celebration I'll
of it when there's teams out there that
don't even speak the same language
imagine that you have two teams they
don't speak the same language the
referees sometimes are from a third
country so that could they could nobody
speaking the same language and they all
are they brought together under this
common sport and it's uh and the passion
you see the passion in the audience you
see women crying about it you don't see
that and in American sports really you
don't see like a beauty like a beautiful
lady crying because her team isn't doing
well you know and usually you know
sometimes you see that in LA like in the
you know up in like the you know in
these fancy you know box seats or
something love some rich lady up there
maybe they run out of coke or something
and she's a little ticked off you know
and so she's texting somebody you know
trying to maybe grab a few extra grams
and they're not texting back and so
she'll be you know she'll be salt water
and up straight out our holes but these
this is the passion you see you see
father and son in the crowd and they are
just I don't know there's something
about it where it's like especially at a
time when everybody acts like the world
is so bad but yet you have all these
countries getting together and that's
the truth
the truth is her these these countries
aren't coming you don't see people
hating each other in the stands there's
a camaraderie there's a respect it's
almost like I wish any wars that we had
any more it's just the ammunition with
soccer balls and the weapons were feet
and they just had a war cup and that's
what it was it was a war Cup and whoever
wins the air or whoever wins the World
Cup every year gets to be the leader of
the free world and just seeing like how
different teams play you know you'd have
a I watched Senegal and they played like
a certain like you know they played
kinda like the ball was hot they would
just you know there was so much extra of
movement almost wasted movement it
seemed like sometimes you have the
French you know and they seem like
complete [ __ ] even when they're
playing soccer you know people are
cheering for Belgium you have
you had the Japanese team that didn't
seem to fake as many injuries you know I
noticed that there was a level of
dishonor there if they seem to fake
injuries whereas these other teams I
mean America faked a bunch of injuries
and didn't even [ __ ] make it into the
[ __ ] you know and it kind of put it in
perspective to about America it's like
America is a great country no doubt man
just the the fact that that probably
99.9% of us get to lay in bed in a bed
at night and and feel and have food and
water inside of us you know it makes it
a really special place and I made those
numbers up but I mean you know I'm
saying this probably is semi-closed so
America you know where it's it's
obviously a place is doing well but it
made me start to think like like me like
it's just so much responsibility you
know being like the leader of the free
world you know and even just that tight
like wherever that came from you know
it'd be nice to just go back to just
being a country kind of you know just
one of many
it made me bum that America wasn't in it
you know the World Cup it's just man
it's just amazing I think it's amazing
that all these countries can get
together and play and the beauty you get
to see you could see how beautiful it is
you know you see whole families out
there in the stands you see father and
son like hugging and you know even
kissing there's definitely some mouth
kissing in some of those Croatians
boy I said you know I saw a five-way
kiss between a family and I'm like I
don't think that's you know that's gonna
end up on a you know probably on the
dark web or something there's gonna be
definitely some businessman paying for
that but it was it's just been
fascinating to me and then the sacrifice
you make as a just as a viewer right now
you have to wake up and like it's almost
like paying homage you know because this
the games will be on at 7:00 a.m. you
have to wake up and like and be there
sometimes 5:00 a.m. they were on so you
have to wake up and be there it was
almost like wild like waiting for the
Sun to rise but it's just been
remarkable and I think it just seems
like something that just brings
everybody together and it's like if I
turn away from the news a lot of shits
really really good most of most people
aren't fight
anymore all about all this boat most
people aren't it's kind of just the same
people that won't shut up you know and
it's just the same lame-o's I want to
keep writing articles and all you know
that a lot of it I don't feel like it's
new information a lot of it it's like if
you get out in the world and you feel
what's going on then you feel what's
going on
you know I think there's a storm of
instinct coming back into us as humans
right now even though at the same time
oddly I feel like it's leaving us
because because of like all the you know
the the lack of connection through you
know that we're all more on our phones
and we're more you know we're not doing
as much human connection but I think
there's something roaring back where
there's an instinct as a desire you know
but yeah I've just enjoyed the World Cup
I don't even know what I'm talking about
I'm kind of rambling I've really enjoyed
it though and I've enjoyed just like
watch those penalty kicks and it's all
on the line and you can feel a whole
[ __ ] I mean you can feel it it's crazy
when you can feel the get you can feel
it and then sometimes a team will score
right and then the whole second half
they'll just have to not get scored on
and they'll win one to nothing and a
team will just try and kick the ball
under the goal like 70 times in a row
and my friend who is who honestly could
probably go to jail for some stuff but
we are friends he said that um it's
called suffering where your team just
suffers you just they kick the ball and
it hit you in the face and hit you in
the neck and the nuts and your buddy
doesn't even [ __ ] have nuts anymore
because he got hitting the nuts so many
times he [ __ ] left his nuts in
another country and it just keep people
getting hit and people getting their
eyelashes ripped off and one guy just
you know just [ __ ] just going into a
coma because he got hit by the ball in
the back of the head and you just get
hit and you suffering it just ends and
you're running in it and and finally the
whistle blows and you're like wow we did
it and it's just it just like it feels
almost like it's like the closest thing
I feel like I've ever seen like a war
you know and no uh you know no
disrespect to our troops but it says the
closest thing I feel like I've ever seen
no to a war is this World Cup and it's
and it's peaceful you know it's exciting
and it's adventurous and it's and it's
violent and it's but it's artistic and
it's peaceful and it's just been
exceptional and look I'm not a soccer
guy I'm not a soccer guy it's just
there's something the emotion there's
this Orchestra within it all there's
this [ __ ] there's this mozart to it
all when some of these people play well
that just grips me in and just tickles
me inside of my inside of my brain and
in my even my man dick at the same time
and it's incredible and it makes me feel
something and that's what I'm looking
for you know that's what I'm looking for
but it made me think a lot about America
it made me think a lot about like race
you know because all these races were
out there playing you're not seeing it
you know yeah like you know it seems
like there's more racism like in the NFL
then there is in these games but then of
course like you know these players
aren't miked up we have no clue what
they're saying but it did make me think
a lot about America you know and I've
just had a lot of thoughts this week I
mean we had the Jordan Peterson episode
came out last week and a win on Joe
Rogan's podcast last week and uh and man
I mean you talk about being like a
podcast heaven
it's been a lot you know it's been it's
really really been a lot so it's you
know I I don't even know what to think
about it and then part of me just like
well don't think about it you know just
keep going forward just do whatever you
got to do next and there's no goal or
anything but it's just been you know to
sit in here in the studio with you know
it was someone I consider a very pure
thinker you know whenever I was talking
to mr. Peterson
you know I was just I wanted to try and
just learn more about his feelings you
know when I was nervous okay let's say
this I was nervous and I was nervous
because I'll let me think because I just
didn't know as much as him you know I
don't know as much you know I've read
some things you know I've seen and I've
seen some things
you know I watched a dude one time
speaking of soccer I saw a man one time
with a paper a paper sack of nails and
he kicked it here and he's like I'm a
kicked he's [ __ ] this this paper sack
of nails over that house and he ran and
kicked his sack of nails and the sack
cracked open and like 20 in the hills
got stuck in his foot and that was it so
I know some things I know not to do that
kind of [ __ ] but this was uh you know
this is you know this is a man who it's
almost like he it's almost like he like
kind of pared down the Bible in a way
and and presented it in a way to people
today where it's even if you're not even
religious even just bother his twelve
steps book that it presented in a way to
people where it's it's a little bit
digestible and it's just very back to
the basics and so it was just
fascinating you know it's fascinating to
be in his company and it was and I was
nervous at the same time and I didn't
want to you know you just agree with him
about everything and I didn't but I also
didn't want to have a big plan you know
and I wanted to try and hope I just
wanted to try and maybe get to know him
a little bit you know in and I you know
I did have other questions I wish I
would I asked him like are we gonna be
okay are men gonna be okay
you know why does it feel sometimes like
we're at the guillotine is humanity
gonna be okay
and who maybe he does I'm not saying he
has any answers but I do am saying it he
has he has more elements to include in
his periodic table of answer ship than I
do you know he just has more area he has
more angles he's coming from so but you
know it but it was fun but I had you
know obviously it was great and it was
interesting and it was great it was good
to spend time at rogue it was just like
a crazy podcast week it was a crazy
podcast week man and what else I was
thinking about America you know I was
thinking a lot about America you know
over fourth of July and World Cup and
and I have this it seems like a lot of
people these days and a lot of like
article writers and stuff there
like you know we you know America needs
diversity in American he says and look
America is quickly becoming extremely
more diverse than it was when I was a
kid and that will not change and that's
great that's the direction America is
headed right but one thing I think is
and I was talking to some friends of
mine who were from China because I'm
actually going to China this week and I
and and I'm I'm like is it weird
sometimes that we it's almost like we're
trying to change America
it's like oh people are moving here from
Guam then we need to make America more
like Guam so they feel comfortable but
that's not the truth for me it isn't for
me it feels like and I'm happy to be
wrong that um that America wants to be
this thing you know it wants to be this
wild fancy cat you know a cat that also
songs where as a raccoon fur coat you're
like dang is that cat wearing cone yes
it is you know and so and so people
don't they don't want you to to kill the
rack to kill the cat in the raccoon coat
they don't want you to change you know
people they don't want to come from Guam
and be like oh good this is just like
Guam they want to be accepted but we
don't have to make America a different
place to fit everybody that's not a
[ __ ] country that's an airport you
know that's a gas station you know we
want to have what if something for
everybody what we do want to have
something for everybody and that's
acceptance but I think we can also still
have this thing that America is and yes
some of the things that America is are
dumb some of them are awesome but that's
just like everywhere else dude bro some
there's one country um China
somebody my buddies tell me you can eat
dick over there you could buy a couple
little sack of [ __ ] dicks dude what
now there are there big articles in
China saying we gotta you know people
who you know know more dicks people want
salmon when they come here no because
it's China you go there to get you know
you we're there you want it to be what
it is
and in Psych I don't think we should
sacrifice whatever America is you know
the good like as if that's bad for us
you know as if like oh it's the same old
apple pie and cheddar cheese and you
know and people you know [ __ ] and
drinking Mountain Dew so what then
that's what it is man things will evolve
but at the same time like you know we
can't turn America it's not Epcot Center
I think he can still be America and
people can come to America and they can
make it oh this is cool this America I
might not be originally American but I
live here so sometimes I feel like
there's this this there's this
unhappiness out there where people like
we have to change everything has to
change nah man don't think as slowly
what is changing over time and and for
some people that's quicker is our hearts
and our ability to accept each other you
know and sometimes that [ __ ] takes a
long time dude you know it takes a long
time some places don't have a lot of
diversity doesn't make them a bad place
but it's gonna be unique to them you
can't force [ __ ] overnight it's like
this you know it's like sign this paper
that says you're not you know you've
never had a racist thought I can't be
crazy to sign that I don't think
anybody's net no I don't think anybody
in the world could sign that you know
we're but just because you have thoughts
or you have questions it's like we can't
just get caged up I don't know the [ __ ]
I'm talking I don't know why I got all
serious today
I think Jude I think it's honestly a
byproduct of being around guys like
Jordan Peterson man you know I went in
and uh but yeah man it was just a wild
week to them like I was sitting in here
with Jordan Peterson man The Wizard of
Oz I mean this guy he coughed and a
couple of facts fell out and just hit me
right on the shoulder I mean it was just
fascinating and you know what I'll say
this uh he was very kind and he was very
much like a professor he was very
Canadian he was very polite and I didn't
feel you know sometimes you wonder well
is this
you know if you see if you see somebody
first and then you meet them in real
life you wonder well they're they're
authentic is that the real him is that
who he is
man I'll say this I was searching not
searching for a lack of authenticity but
searching for like you know to see kind
of who else was in there a little bit
and I think he is I think he's pure like
he has his beliefs and he knows that
people can do better and he has done his
research and he is moving forward and he
is genuinely happening about helping
others to feel good and I felt that a
hundred percent you know I felt I felt
that's what I felt I felt it as pure as
pure as I've ever felt it because I
would ask him like you know about ego
you worried about ego when fans come up
and and you know even played a call from
a fan you know when you hear a fan say I
want to say like you know what you
inspired him what do you feel like and
it was never about him you know it was
always like it's all a wave and that's
not him and he's just on the way and and
it was great man it you know it was it
was really really interesting and I feel
grateful I've been in here and I also
feel like I failed myself some you know
I felt like I could have I felt like I
could have been a little more prepared I
felt like I could have been a little
less nervous in the beginning and and I
probably you know and I did kind of like
before we started even just tell him
that I was nervous kind of and I wasn't
nervous as a person you know I wasn't
nervous as a human I was just sometimes
you don't know how people who know more
than you facts
wise are going to are they are going to
show up to you when you do not know as
many facts as them so you know I just
had an inferiority and so I just you
know I felt that but but overall man it
was fascinating and and who knows maybe
we'll get to do it again we have some
other neat guests coming in and so I'm
grateful for that
excited about that and then I got to go
on Joe Rogan and we're talking about
everything and man it just seemed like a
crazy week you know I mean like I just
fell and some people look if you don't
care about those guys and that's fine
but in my world of you know trying to
think about stuff and being less afraid
to to think and trying to match my
thoughts up with my feelings or you know
or separate them even at times being
around people is uh and not being afraid
you know like I like the first times I
went into Joe Rogan and even yesterday
you know I even told Joe that I was just
a little bit nervous you know I'm a
little bit nervous I get nervous if
somebody's physically even if they don't
behave that way but if I purse if I
think that way or have something inside
of me that used to think that way or
there's a moment stuck inside of my body
from 20 years ago where somebody
stronger than me or tougher than me or
smarter than me made me feel a certain
way sometimes those things can live
inside you it's like Easter egg hunt but
you never went hunting for it and that
eggs just been spoiled rotten sitting
inside of your kidney or inside of your
neck or inside of one of your nuts oh I
have I have two nuts nah son you got a
nut and you got a [ __ ] dirty egg down
there and so it's you know it's [ __ ] I
don't know man
I'm just learning as I go I guess I hope
anyway but I want to thank you guys so
much as for the supportive for being a
part of things we got some calls that
came into the hotline I'm sorry I didn't
play more for Jordan Peterson you did
was so it was like because you have to
listen and you have to think and you
have to you know it was just and I
wanted to make sure he felt comfortable
and it's just a lot man it was just and
I'm still learning how to interview
people get I've only interviewed I don't
have any guests we've even had eight
eight guests and one guy was on drugs
this was probably about a year and a
half ago and he was highly on drugs that
boy uneven Stephen and I met him over by
um I met him on the bus and he was all
dapped out dude you know I'm saying like
the Lord had just been you know putting
dirty cotton swabs in and out of his
soul for decades
but hey the Lord didn't do that and he
did that to himself but uh we got the
hot line right here nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three I'm gonna
get into a couple calls we're gonna keep
talking about stuff I know last weekend
I was out of town and I appreciate you
guys being supportive and it was tough
and I'm on the road just some time and
put the episode up but I just you know
is just you know I don't know I guess I
feel it was just kind of a crazy week
and I'm going to China tomorrow didn't
go to Shanghai man well you could be
human some you know saw her you could
eat human dicks over there that's crazy
and some people probably gonna buy a
ticket to come see me just to see a free
person just to see someone who you know
you know who hypothetical has
hypothetical freedom that's crazy
there's gonna be some people while we
come out you know pay whatever is a
ticket $30 whatever I don't even know
what it is just to see somebody who who
may who's free for a little while that's
wild dude it reminds me years ago I went
to the I think it's called the Ben Thanh
market and I definitely could have
butchered that up and that was in
Vietnam and this is um when I was a
student and and they had animals there
and if you buy an animal you can buy a
pig for about eleven dollars and they'll
kill it right there you know one kid
bought a pig you know they had some real
death kids with us people that didn't
mind a little bit of death
you know people if you frisked if you
frisk them you know maybe some animal
carpals would come you know tumbling out
of their pockets you know maybe some mom
you know maybe a [ __ ] a bird clavicle
or two you know people that you know it
was a little bit out there dark art and
caught up in some dirt us and caught up
and just [ __ ] you know if they could
they would just crack open their nuts
and just smell smell just smell it deep
as they could until they just fainted
you know dirty boys and so what happened
was this they had um they they had if
you bought a pig they'd kill it right
there for you because a lot of people
families or whatever or you know they
come and buy an animal and they would
kill it right there and then they take
it on
people would take it home and cook it or
whatever well one guy he bought it and
he's like all - I'm gonna and he stopped
him they almost they had this big huge
butcher knife and they were gonna kill
the animals and inappropriate - here but
not everywhere is like it is in America
you know some places you know if you
order a report chop it comes with a chop
first you know it's that chop port and
this uh and my buddy he like stopped him
like no no not the knife nothing knife
you know and because even that was too
much for the one of these death boys but
then the man literally turned around bow
and arrow
as if it was like like he'd chosen a
different it was just crazy like my
buddy hadn't chosen a different way for
the thing to die he had just he didn't
want it the man to kill it but anyhow
how this goes to me was I oh they had a
bird they are people that had doves
there and I've had dove before a lot of
you guys know that I had a couple of
brothers by me and actually one of Me's
to hook up with this white girl named
labyrinth and you would think that
labyrinth is a little bit more of maybe
uh you know maybe a black girl's name or
you know it could be a but it's also
labyrinth is really more of a white
girls named Tabitha labyrinth what else
um Agatha
you know amethyst a lot of us [ __ ] a lot
of crazy rocks and maze
you know maze labyrinth a lot of places
we could go missing what else
mine shaft that's not a name mine shaft
that's crazy dude so but anyway so and
these brothers mommy used to grill up
dove outside of our apartment so I go
out there they asked me for years hey
man you want to cut of this dove and I
never had any and then finally I had a
little bit of dove and you know I don't
really I don't want to eat peace meets
you know I never been a manís you know I
don't want to put a [ __ ] you know you
know I don't want to have a jaw full of
just [ __ ] straight up relaxation and
joy for the world you know I don't like
peace it I don't want to eat a piece
meat like a dove
you know some animals have peace in them
doves disabled animals donkeys what else
flamingos that's kind of a [ __ ] peace
meet you know I'm saying you don't see a
flamingo you don't see him fight you
don't see him kicking people even they
have long legs they could kick you from
you know at least two feet away and
that's all that's you know that's a lot
for a bird but anyway something like I'm
a rescue one of these doves I'm gonna
buy the Dove I'm gonna let it loose
outside nobody's gonna kill this one
today at this Vietnamese market so i go
in i buy the Dove I get it I run outside
throw the Dove right it goes about eight
feet lands on the ground and it's still
alive and immediately a man walks over
picks it up rings its neck takes it home
and that's that you know and that's that
so sometimes you're in places you don't
know what's going on and things are
different and those are the rules and
those are the ways and you just have to
you just have to get on board you know
sometimes your perception of what it's
gonna be like it's not the same you know
so I try not to I'm trying not to go in
there in a shanghai with any perceptions
you know a friend of mine told me that
it the other day that um you know What
did he say he said that expectations are
resentments waiting to happen
that's what he said to me and I was like
my him and that expectations our
resentments waiting to happen so how do
I get into a place where I don't have
those expectations you know and some of
them you want to keep you know sometimes
I want to keep that vision when I was
young and I said oh ah you know I'd like
to have that house with the porch and
I'd like to be out there sitting with a
you know with my wife and um and have a
trust between us or have an honesty
between us you know there's some things
uh you know that you want you know but
but then if I pin my tail too much to
that donkey to that you know
subconscious donkey inside of me into
that vision donkey that you know that
future idea donkey then you know I might
miss the place I'm supposed to settle in
I might miss an avenue that I'm supposed
to take so I
some of this just about growing up and
learning about my own instincts but I
want to thank you guys for hitting the
hotline I know I'm talking fast it I
haven't eaten a lot I got a flower early
but I'm staying here with you guys I'm
happy to be here we got a gift that came
in as well I'm gonna open it up at the
end of the podcast and super excited
about that as well
here we go I'm just going to
congratulate you on having Jordan
Peterson first of all on your podcast
and then being on the Joe Rogan
experience I thought that was really
amazing I thought you I thought you told
the show honestly I don't know why Joe
wasn't just laughing and crying in tears
but you're doing really great things I
think you're about to take off and I
think of things in your future love you
love yourself calculator thanks for the
call yeah and I appreciate that and um
yeah look I mean I felt like [ __ ] I
felt like bo Jackson dude you know I
felt a little bit you know here's the
thing it's like you don't want to say
well I feel out of my league you know
but I don't want to say that I feel in
my league you know I'm saying I want to
always be out of my league I want to
always be you know I want to always kind
of have that mind
oh I always want to feel okay in my old
clothes you know you know I had this
idea that um that I never want to put on
like my old clothes and feel like I'm
too good for them you know and I know
you're some of you guys may be like well
how does this pertain any of this but
look man if you to ask me three months
ago do you think you'll be on Joe Rogan
and interviewing Jordan Peterson in the
same week now and look I might never
look at them and that's like you know
that's when uh what's-his-name Sugar Ray
Robinson or whatever you know won the
title and I think what else happened and
that guy he [ __ ] didn't he kill a
couple people in a car accident but
that's like that's not I mean that's not
that's a worse comparison
what happened oh that's like didn't they
have somebody that was skydiving and hit
a donkey or something and it busted the
animal open in the head up
they found it had like I swallowed her
wedding ring or something of someone's
and you know the way you know is like
very expensive and the family have been
looking for that yeah so it's more like
that it's like you know when something
happens and then something else happens
you don't expect it but yeah it was um
you know yeah it was just crazy week but
yeah but thanks for tuning in and and uh
and yeah I guess I always want to have
that thing where I'm in the minor
leagues I always want to have that thing
where I [ __ ] I don't know man with
[ __ ] my even talking about let's take
another call here I just you know I
think I would feel sad if I met if I
felt like my old clothes if I wasn't
good if I was too good for my old
clothes because I don't know what this
means or I don't know this making me
feel kind of strange but because I don't
you know my old clothes when they were
never too good for me you know like they
never you know it's never like I went to
my closet one day and my clothes were
like nah nah man you know we don't know
you're not allowed here you know we
don't accept you here or we don't man I
don't know this shit's got me tearing up
I don't even know why either you know
what is it what am I thinking about you
know why wonder why this had me feeling
like kind of I don't know y'all
never yeah well here's the thing it's
like we can adapt so quickly you know
you can adapt so quickly to feeling like
oh I deserve here or I deserve here and
it's not even something you do as a
person I don't think I think it's some
it's something built into us you know
it's the same I think I've talked about
this before it's like when you see
somebody eating out of a dumpster if you
if you to ask that person previously
would you ever eat out of a dumpster no
way they would say but then there they
are
it's like and a year later they could be
eating in a row five star restaurant
again with their life back on track or
the life on a different track if they
chose to eat out of the dumpster but and
they and they would again say no I would
never do that again
you know it's just we are so adaptable
and we'll get used to things very quick
and so I just you know I don't want to
you know I just don't I don't know let's
go let's go on we're men cuz I'm getting
kind of stuck here but thank you for you
guys as patients and also wanna let you
know that in Shanghai I will be in
Shimon on Thursday July 12th July 13th
I'll be in Shanghai and July 14th I'll
be in Shanghai in Thursday and Shimon I
am at the Swiss Grand shame in and then
in Shanghai I'm at cages and comedy you
in so those are the places if you know
somebody in Shanghai somebody's China
you know somebody pork chop chop pork
bring em out bring em out and I'm gonna
do my best and I'm definitely nervous as
well so many people have emailed me
about diarrhea somebody sent me a
picture of people you know a man that
went there and weighed like 180 pounds
and left they're weighing 111 pounds
well don't [ __ ] send me that what do
you want me to do about that I'm not
looking for that
guy don't send me that that's once a cat
[ __ ] man that's in that manger Ange bro
leave daddy off of that [ __ ] Call
Sheet
because I'm out of that [ __ ] dirty
fireworks man
you know I'm saying I smoke my own dick
in a [ __ ] part bro for I'm living
like that
alright I'm letting you know that I'll
be in Raleigh North Carolina July 20th
and 22nd after that I'll be in
Minneapolis Chicago Nashville Toronto
Appleton Wisconsin and other places you
can go to Theo von comm slash tour t oh
you are let's get to a caller here
thanks for calling the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three onward hey what's up I was just
calling in with a suggestion so my
suggestion is go work is made for a
little while I seen that you were
talking about tipping your mains other
day which I appreciate because my first
job was working at a maid and it taught
me more about you know different types
of people I was working with women that
had been a prison and then women who
couldn't speak English and they were
forced into like almost like a type of
slavery where they you know couldn't
speak out if they were being mistreated
you see this happen most people leave
and just how people can treat you and
they think that you're below them so I
think that sometimes we get too caught
up on news and made at the super 8
anyway thank you for calling use a mate
at the super 8 and you sound like a
super tin to me you sound like a like a
like a perfect score young lady and
that's a you know it is a wild job and
I'm you know I for me when it comes to
tip and I just try and tip where I feel
you know I ain't no [ __ ] Robin Hood
but I tip where I can man you know I tip
I can and I tip where I feel it's
necessary and I do two hotel rooms
people are naughty and yeah the maid
comes in there think about that
do most people write when they get into
a hotel room they take all their shirts
off people's jerky and Alf live in life
wildly no I'm saying you people are you
know there's some people you know jerked
off or they've even cut the the
television Olin what who goes into a
room and jerks off before they turn on
the TV huh huh who is someone who's sick
so yeah these ladies you gotta remember
to drop that five drop that ten for a
for a cleaning lady if some lady's
coming into a room where someone could
still be hiding and is gonna clean up
you know cookie crumbs and semen at the
same time you're not gonna give them
five bucks dude
you're out of your [ __ ] mind bro
think about your mind now think about
you not inside of it
yep that's what's going on give him the
[ __ ] money you snake okay
but thanks for calling I never worked at
a super 8 you know I never worked at a
super 8 I learned I work at oh they used
to have this girl who'd made me come up
there and she would uh you know let me
touch her you know touch that coot or a
little and she was so scared bro she was
loud right she was that vivacious you
know that vivacious character and so she
would start just howling I mean it was
like every time he touched her vagine
just seemed like you were just petting a
[ __ ] cat that was made out of all
nerves you know just like a cat that
just had not you know about 70 clitoris
is on its back you know like a like a
like a like a like a um like a cat like
a cat like a cactus like a click
catasaurus like a [ __ ] catasaurus and
you know you would just just stroke that
lady one time and she would just set off
I mean like the Sun and Roz like the Sun
had just risen and she was the first
person to see it I mean like she just
had a [ __ ] like she had nine trumpets
living in her in her throat and the King
just [ __ ]
showed up boy and so what she would do
is she would print they had a really
loud printer there and this is kind of
dumb in hindsight but this is how this
is what happens when you know two people
are ignorant and me and her were
together and both of us were ignorant
and this is what happens so she put the
printer on and it would print really
loudly and then that's when I would
touch her you know and she would welcome
that touch you know and sometimes she
would um you know she would uh I
remember even she would take her
underpants off and kind of put him
around her neck and even blindfold
herself with him and that but that was
crazy to me cuz I don't understand that
part because you know they weren't they
weren't like big Underpants and she
could definitely see through them so it
was really like watching somebody who's
cheating she's pretending she's blind
and then hoping for somebody to touch
her crotch at the same time that's some
real you know what I'm saying that's
some that's like a hooker but on the
walking dead you know I mean that's that
Helen Keller hooker right there if you
will and I know that that's kind of a
that I shouldn't be thinking about some
of that but yeah but anyway she would
put the printer on cuz the printer would
print real loudly and when that Xerox
it's one of those big huge printers
remember before they had regular
printers when they had this big huge
[ __ ] Cadillac thing had headlights on
it had a trunk in the back had a [ __ ]
dead body in the back had two Italians
outside of it smoked and a couple
[ __ ] dominicanos you know had a
little Hebrew hittin a [ __ ]
calculator out back behind it you know
everybody's everybody's keyed in and and
that's what she would cut that printer
on and just print like 160 documents or
whatever and it would go so loud you
couldn't hear her here her howling
because she'd Hal at that touch you know
she would howl at that touch like a cat
that had a just um you know that its
skin was just full of [ __ ] dangerous
charisma and you would just touch it and
just lightning we just fly out of her
[ __ ] face and that's how excited she
was to share some of that locale cloths
if you feel me but yeah but so I've
spent a little bit of time at a super8
but thank you so much for calling in and
I make sure to tip it cleanly
we got to do it you know some of this
other [ __ ] you tipping you know somebody
here some people need that cash man drop
a five to your [ __ ] mailman you know
hide a couple dollars in your buddy's
ass when he's resting you know I'm
saying friendship you know better than
deserve a couple of dollars here and
there Kim okay these are some follow-ups
to last week we had a guy who called in
I believe 29 year old virgin let's check
on that call first
what's up feel its exact from Toronto
Canada Zach from Toronto I'll be up
there in Toronto a little bit later this
year so get those passes to jfl Toronto
more so my conundrum is that I'm 29 and
I never had sex with a girl Wow
dude I got to think about this man
because you're 29 you never had sex huh
Wow because yeah let's hear let's listen
to you we've listened to me enough let's
sorry I interrupted you Zach more you
know and it's not like I'm not a freak
I'm a bear dude you know I'm like six to
like 230 240 bro you sound cute enough
this girl's listening right now who
would probably [ __ ] your bra and a
couple dudes too bro so one way or
another we might get you out of this Jam
let's hear more and you know I've been
spending a lot of time just working on
my education I got some university
degrees oh man so I'll tell you what you
are [ __ ] dude you're [ __ ] the
world bro did you get yourself some uh
some diplomas no you you you know you
know I'm saying he's stacking that paper
he's stacking that that you know those
frame fillers man you got a couple
hitters more and trying to get a career
off the ground but it's like I've never
had sex with a girl and I'm and I never
really pursued either Wow so you're well
I mean I I mean a Joe Rogan talks about
this thing called the N cells I think
and it's people that don't have no
interest in sex at all I don't know if
that's what you are cuz I have to
research it a little bit more and that's
just and also you could just be your own
thing but this is super interesting man
I'd love to I'm have to call you and
talk
on the air about this but let's finish
your call but I'm starting to think like
the English in just a look and be
celibate forever dude I heard this and
if you don't have sex and you go to
heaven bruh that there's like everybody
it's like you're like a pinata and they
beat you open and um and all alike the
semen and all that confetti or whatever
like you know because semen is basically
just confetti but from like heaven and
it um it all flies out of your body that
people beat you open and it flies out of
your body but it doesn't hurt it's still
you know but it's just like it's like a
celebration it's like a maypole
celebration or something like that or
like I guess like Cinco de Maya or
something more and also my buddy my
buddy even he really likes those [ __ ]
right okay he's out there escorting more
and he even offered to pay for me to
[ __ ] her and I said no cause I'm not
that kind of [ __ ] but I don't know what
do you think about that you know it's
like 29 years old never had sex with a
girl I got my dick sucked once but as a
while ago I don't know what do you think
and let's we had some callers that hit
the hotline in in response with some
suggestions and thoughts here we go
I feel like a wife from Indiana what's
up West from Indiana and that is Spanish
for Indian Indian and that's the Daily
Double
okay homeward they're 29 year old virgin
call it and point of the 29 year old
virgin is I think it's all about olives
at first then I realized he talking
about this man let's hear more we could
do okay yeah whatever
yeah he was asking if uh if he should
get a hooker or a prostitute or an
escort or you know or uh you know
somebody who's you know tied their
panties around their face and is
pretending they can't see even though
it's just a small office and all the
lights are on you know in the back of a
you know in like a Ramada kind of office
onward and you don't want to be bad
I respect the first time with someone
you actually care about
all right I think there might not be a
way to go but it sounds like it might be
the way to go
I'm kind of leaning on your side of
things on that okay so you're saying
that you don't want to a hooker might be
the way to go so you have some cuz yeah
what if he gets to that moment with
somebody he cares about and then they
judge him you know would if and then
maybe they're not the person for them if
they judge in this man on that first
[ __ ] you know that first [ __ ] attempt
dude I remember the first night I slept
over with a girl in that I was in love
with in college and I did I've been you
know doing a bunch of alcohol and
ingesting a bunch of alcohol and the
next thing you know I urinated all over
the couch
and she and I were on the couch and some
like [ __ ] dude and bro I even tried to
go get cups of water and like splash
them against the ceiling you know I was
gonna say there was a leak and I'm like
on the third cup I [ __ ] hit the
ceiling with it and I'd put a little bit
of kool-aid powder in there because the
water wasn't if you throw water against
a ceiling it just kind of splashes down
it doesn't leave like a a mark that
looks like it's been coming from above
something and I got to get this water a
little bit darker so it'll leave a
little bit of a element up there you
know it'll leave a little bit of water
mains up there you know some coloring so
she'll be like oh yeah it came down so I
put a little bit of [ __ ] kool-aid
powder bruh you know that chirpy purple
or whatever that [ __ ] is you know busty
horns or whatever this shit's called you
know Cavalier cherry you know or uh
Catechism lemon or whatever the
different flavor is but it was purple
you know some of that chirpy purple and
I threw it up against the ceiling and
and it just [ __ ] all came back down I
mean it just it was stupid and then a
lot of it came back down and she [ __ ]
woke up and uh and yeah it's just like
it's stupid but but yeah anyway
sometimes you um you know you just got
to be careful I don't mean what I was
talking about let's hear the rest of
your call thank you for calling or about
being a virgin oh I'm just saying yeah
sometimes sexual it's not everything you
want it to be even if you want it to be
something important more
and uh I don't know they should just do
it just do it
that's a first-time call just I try to
help some people how bloody say oh man
keep it up thank you and thank you for
calling from Indiana and you know in
Indiana I'm not calling you guys out but
you guys they started the I think the Ku
Klux Klan or started there and a lot of
people think it was in the south and it
was actually in Indiana so you know but
you know other good stuff started there
too basketball so you know some one
thing that was good for different
ethnicities and one thing that was bad
for different ethnicities so it's you
know it's definitely hit or miss out
there you know it's hit or miss um what
was I gonna say about if you get the
escort here's the thing if you get an
escort and here's what people don't
realize also a bad escorts I'm thinking
about this these ladies are the night
these women that are prostituting and I
don't have an issue with an escort I
don't think that it's I think that it's
if there's a you know if it's a there's
women out there it is their means to an
end and do I think it's a safe place to
play in I don't and I do I think it's
you know at that point you're caught up
in the in the in the dark arts I do you
know because there's a lot of potential
for danger because Oh an escort usually
can't call the police because they're
doing a crime so you know they don't
have the protection of the police so
that means they're going to places
completely with with no law in the world
and then the potential for harm is so
much more severe so you know that's that
can be wild now something that's crazy
is this
I remember my buddy and I you know we
are invested in a hooker and I'm not
saying you might think this is crazy you
might think this is but whatever this in
your life so we invested in a hooker and
she was a she was excited about being a
hooker and we were excited about being
being hooked and we actually had decided
it was like okay well you know you know
we'll make sure that this lady's cool
and stuff so she comes over and in that
picture these two pictures on the
internet they shut these sites down now
and she comes over and there is a pimp
with her and you know an angry man and a
pimp is an angry man it's like a cashier
but he's got to wait a while to get the
money and so he's just angry and he and
this man also you could tell you didn't
he didn't he slow down a little he
didn't have a weapon but you could tell
he he didn't show a weapon but you could
tell he had a weapon so anyhow next
thing you know this escort it's not the
same one as the pictures it's a
different woman and it's a woman that if
you saw the pictures you'd be like nah
I'm not gonna get I don't want that one
that's not I don't want this escort
that's not a neat place to to you know
to [ __ ] or to be sexual with this per
don't desire this person so instead the
escort then has the escort then but now
the pimp is there so you still got to
pay the pimp so my buddy was like well
he had already said well go in first you
know what I'm saying I'll be in there
and spend time with this lady and I was
super nervous super nervous I mean I get
nervous if I even pull my dick out and
there is um you know and the neighbors
are still awake and I'm saying if I even
pull my dick out and I'm home alone and
I can smell the neighbors are still
cooking dinner or chat and after dinner
over some dessert
man I'm sofa I am so nervous and I love
dessert and so now my buddy's like dude
I don't want this I don't I'm not
attracted to this escort it's not the
same one of the pictures but the pimp
wants his money and my buddy didn't want
to waste his money so now my buddy is
basically having to have sex with a
woman that he doesn't want to have sex
with because the pimp is like don't
waste our time and my buddy's like [ __ ]
I you know I kind of envy
tested here so it's just a dangerous
world out there but is that the kind of
world you want to lose your virginity in
does it does your virginity matter that
much at this point is it still is it
weighing on you heavily you know I'm
really curious about this twenty nine
years old and still a virgin it's very
rare these days I mean dude there's post
at this place is you can to you know you
can trip over a curb and literally fall
into some [ __ ] that you know somebody
be laying on the beach you go to India
there's so many people in everywhere
that if you just put on a blindfold and
run forward with an erection you're
gonna land in some [ __ ] bruh now it
might be illegal but but that's you know
you'll deal with that then and then you
know you have to make some amends let's
hear more
what's up vo this is Eric from Virginia
I'm calling about that the 29 year old
virgin yep thanks for calling Eric
onward look he fed himself that a you
know he hasn't really been pursuing it
so it's obviously not that big a deal to
him so I mean my advice would be you
know just keep doing what you're doing
you know like if it happens naturally
that's cool you know but if not who
cares you know because I mean you know
my advice is just don't go out here
looking for some casual sex if there's
nothing that they can do to you because
you're probably going to be disappointed
anyway Gang Gang Gang baby Gang Gang and
yeah you know that's that's the legit
point that man has from Virginia because
look if the history is what it is that
you haven't been having it then are you
just fighting against your own history
just let it come casual because look you
could run around all day with your hands
in the air trying to catch a a sparrow
right you could do it but you could wait
til a bird hit you right in the [ __ ]
dick
see you never
man you never know but sometimes it's up
to you to let it play out let's hear
more we got another call that came in
here uh the last one about the same
twenty nine year old virgin homeward I
feel this is Nicole I just wanted to see
something to that twenty nine year old
version thank you for calling Nicole um
and I love how we all it's just
immediately we have all called him the
29 year old virgin and that's media you
know the movie did that to us 40 year
old virgin seventy year old virgin is
like that's got to be happening soon huh
how is that not a movie seventy year old
virgin I'd watch that
dude I'd watch 16 year old virgin I
wouldn't watch like the poor I wouldn't
watch any set but I would watch you know
a young person dealing with that I mean
they had that movie kids a long time ago
you know and it's about some kids in New
York that are trying to [ __ ] each other
in like a three-story apartment or
something I think by a park let's hear
more thank you for calling young lady um
you know you have a lot going on for you
do you who are over 60 tall
you have an education you aren't super
desperate to get laid which girls are
kinda into now oh that's a good point
yeah and look man insect I think you you
could be the Christopher Columbus of no
[ __ ] you feel me you could be the
Christopher Columbus of not getting [ __ ]
my brother because I'll you know it's
it's I don't say this to be brew tea or
to say you know I'm not trying to put
any shame on you sex is everywhere sex
is everywhere dude the other day my
buddy something fell on him at a
department store it was a bunch of [ __ ]
you know sex is everywhere and tits and
even some tits I think and sex is
everywhere that's what I'm saying is
that's a metaphor that's a high pot
that's a um that's a metaphor or an
allegory for the fact that sex is
everywhere and so what isn't everywhere
is holding the line what isn't
everywhere is substantiality
what isn't everywhere is not giving in
to temptation because temptation this is
a temptation time we live in the
temptation belt and where is that
I don't know everywhere everywhere is
temptation everywhere turn around now
turn back around dude you saw [ __ ] at
least two temptations and I'm not
talking about the black beautiful black
musicians I'm talking about full time
temptation now a hundred and twenty
hours a week it never ends and so to to
have to be a virgin these days come on
yeah man mmm that special man you know
I'm saying and look at and if I'm gonna
call you this week let's chat this week
because I want to see I'm gonna be in
China but I'll figure it out and I'd
love to just kind of see what you want
at what you're thinking about it after
you hear some of these suggestions and
and kind of what you feel about it
because you know if we can we'd love to
you know we're not trying to facilitate
anything Universal but maybe there's a
lady out there who's a virgin
you know we had Danielle the virgin
earlier this year and she you know she
dropped that thing off no I'm saying
she dropped that off at the at the vag
Austin found somewhere she gave it to a
man and she put it on a man to said she
hurt the mans ankle she was [ __ ] and
him you know [ __ ] and him so hard
so we'll see what else happens but there
you go a couple options experiment with
the escort before you go to a lady okay
the second option is let me see
experiment an escort for you go to a
real lady wait because you haven't had
yeah it hasn't been super important yet
so wait and the third option is you have
good characteristics here's a woman
telling you you know like that you there
are other things are more important to
you obviously you are tall you are
you can speak well you know here's a
lady right here who's who has is showing
you that women are interested in you and
just hold the line let's stay away from
those temptations you know and I'm sure
you had expectations that's a crazy
thing you probably expected to drop off
that vagina you know
and we had a girl at our school do it I
think is in this honestly this was a
black girl and her name was virginity
you know virgin a 10-watt son and and I
used to play basketball with her brother
Courtney wants and and it's like you
know you have expectations that you're
not going to have it forever or that you
are going to have it forever and then
what's happening you probably thought
she's gonna get rid of it you know you
thought probably thought you're gonna
get off the school bus one day and some
girls is gonna come out you know come on
and just let her let you hitch a ride up
in the air but that changed and that
hasn't happened and then you probably
thought oh my go to college you know and
I'll be up one night and just you know
maybe some girl come by to water water
the plants but suddenly you know the
plants will be my cake and the water
will be that one and then we'll be doing
sex then you probably thought oh well
college is almost over I'm gonna go to
my buddy's wedding and he'll he'll
invite some girls who were definitely
down the [ __ ] dude
these chicks like the fog and nothing
will pan out there it and but nothing
happened you know you got to drunk that
she got too drunk when y'all vomited
into the fire and that was the last that
was the point in the night where it was
maybe gonna happen when with somebody
vomits into a fire a lot of vomit cooks
if it's a thick vom that [ __ ] cooks up
you know if you got a little bit of grit
in your V mitt that [ __ ] cooks up and so
then it you know ruins the fire ruins
the party but uh anyhow so a couple of
options there but let's get some other
calls that came in just some regular
people hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three here
we go it was a deal it's uh Gary from
San Antonio going to drive with Austin
the night to work what's up Derek from
San Antonio and you're gonna drive up to
Austin so be safe out there if you on
them streets man because anything could
happen you know they had a uh I remember
one time I passed out at an intersection
and apparently they had two wolves got
in a fight in the street and I'm
unconscious dude you know or mentally
unconscious I think it's called and I've
been drinking and you know and also was
operating a motor vehicle
and uh and instead of driving I guess I
just went to sleep at a stoplight and
then I officer showed up knocked on my
window put the flashlight on me I wake
up he goes um did you see two wolves out
here fighting and I was like what the
[ __ ] bro you think I see wolves man and
I was like nah no sir
you know no sir no sir I didn't see any
sir and he said that somebody called it
in he goes okay well if you see any let
us know and then he [ __ ] left me bro
he left and I was up now inside Rove I
drove home but in that crazy that that
man anyway let's hear more dude thank
you for calling in and I don't even know
what that was about oh just be careful
driving here we go I was just calling
cuz I'm wondering do you have like a
like a flat back of your head is that
why you chose a mullet cuz I mean I cut
my hair like every couple months I just
let it grow and I notice I kind of got a
flat head are you hiding a flat head
behind that mullet I mean I appreciate
you get back to me about that alright
bye okay well appreciate you checking in
about this uh you know about an adult
man's hair and there's nothing wrong
with that you know think about men's
hair over time cavemen had all hair they
used to [ __ ] tie their eyebrows into
their into their into their bangs isn't
it imagine how stupid that looked and a
lot of them did it you know they would
some people grow their beard out tie it
around their neck to keep their hair
back that was also long
so your beard would then you have it
split their beard and use it to tie
their hair back Vikings did that men
would braid their hair white men wore
wigs and their hair white wigs like hey
dude could you be any more [ __ ] white
okay and they put powder in them so that
when they shook their head a little bit
of white smoke fell out men have always
made poor hair choices Prince
kind of a cute guy honestly hair looked
like [ __ ] 100% dude Rosie O'Donnell
never you know not a decent haircut for
a young male
who else bro okay then you go into who
else had hair Oh jheri curl which I
think should come back where's the jheri
curl at huh huh black friends where is
that jheri curl where is it cuz I know
it was hoppin when I was young my
vice-principal had it my buddy's dad had
it you know I'm sayin you used to see
that drip drip that drip drip drip drip
drip let the ladies know you leakin with
swag but no men are fray are brave
enough to bring it back where is it you
know I sometimes I'm like what's up with
these styles y'all afraid
y'all afraid to drip out the back a
little bit y'all afraid to [ __ ] flood
out that hang time to put that floss
floss come and let's see it so men have
always made poor haircut decisions is
what I'm saying but am i hiding a flat
head I don't think so I mean I feel like
this to be totally honest with you I
feel like I have a bigger nose so you
know a lot of the black kids when I was
young would say you have a in nose they
used to say and they would say the
n-word at me about it and also I could
smell you know I know I could smell
pretty good and so you know you got to
have that intake bruh you know and I'm
built like a [ __ ] panther and I need
more air to come in because my brain is
in low function you know when I was
young they said something's wrong with
my brain probably and I don't know who
said it but they wrote it on a napkin
too and my mother has it in my baby book
even but what else was I telling you
about oh I'll tell you this oh do we
hear more your call oh but I don't think
I'm hiding anything you know and I don't
know if this is necessarily a mullet
it's kind of just like a long hair you
know it's crazy it's like some people
you know it's just like a hockey haircut
I guess I mean it's just long hair have
you ever had it I'll tell you this about
having long hair it's changed my life
because what happened was I was looking
at pictures of myself when I was like
man I hate I always hated having short
hair
and I was always afraid to grow up my
long hair and I lived here in Hollywood
like you got to look kind of like a you
know yo you're gonna be a leading man I
ain't a [ __ ] leading man boy you know
I'm saying I'm a sidekick daddy you know
so I'm looking like I'm gonna look and
so I grew my Mane out until if I die if
I die out there in the desert or in a
mountain or if I fall into a wishing
well and I die even though I have so
many wishes and none of them get me out
of there I want them to look and see me
and say that man had a mane that was a
man or a very thin lesbian that man or
her dead but they had a style they had
some passion hanging off the back of our
neck
I don't be out there this [ __ ] oh the
Sun might get me oh it's uh uh
anything could happen all the rains
gonna hit me some of the rains not gonna
get me when I got this style
what's that weather ooh maybe nothing
cuz I have a little bit of protection I
got a Maine boy and if you see me in the
desert or you see me outside sometimes
at night I'll turn around and be nine
raccoons behind me with their dicks out
cuz they [ __ ] can feel that I am a
man onward but thank you for calling man
I do appreciate it dude and I didn't
mean to get kind of fired up but Lenny
whatever let's hear more so Theo von
this is Brian out of Santa Cruz I was
just calling to let you know that that
last episode with you and Whitney man if
I have ever seen a mating dance that was
a beautiful mating dance between two
powerful comics and thank you for
calling Brian from Santa Cruz and if you
don't know it's Santa Cruz their team
name the college team name is the banana
slug
and banana slug is also that's not a
rate is it a racial slur so I think they
should change that [ __ ] but uh but you
know what it's probably a bunch of
[ __ ] you know whatever you know it's
time we quit [ __ ] say you know people
should do this or do that people should
live their lives that's what I think but
I think it's something against Hawaiians
or something but anyway let's hear more
and interesting people
oh and he's talking about me and I
Whitney Cummings was on the podcast
let's hear more people that basically
courted each other for a future marriage
and I gotta say man if stars line up
right I've seen you two together Wow so
you saying you think me and Whitney
Cummings was out there doing that dirty
dance huh
showing that um because one of my
buddies used to paint the underside of
his nuts and he would pull it up real
high and show it to women sometimes if
there was like a party like kind of
early not an early evening like early
evening kind of late afternoon party and
and some one lady's husband beat the
[ __ ] out of that dude once but uh but
let's hear more uh I think she gave you
the nod and I know you've been giving
her the nod for a couple years probably
and who knows man I know she's in a
relationship but if that don't work out
you know and you you step up your game
to her level
and she tones down her game a little bit
to your level I can see you two making
it work Wow who knows you know I don't
know uh uh I mean I think that I think
that she's a confident and strong woman
I think those are things that are
admirable about her I mean I want to
have a family you know so I don't know
if that's something she seems very
interested in she I think she's maybe a
little too highfalutin for me but but
look you never know man
but yeah and I was saying my buddy would
paint the underside of his nuts like a
peacock and show it like that and then
that's when you know that's when that
guy beat his ass eventually and that was
I guess at about 4:30 p.m.
pretty
but thank you for calling a man and look
that's you know whatever gets you
through the night if you want to imagine
me and Whitney you know being naughty
and playing [ __ ] you know playing DNA
hockey with each other go go go
that's me scoring camp then nah then
that's fine with me man you know I used
to imagine this lady I knew given Cedric
the Entertainer hand jobs and that would
help me have a little bit more energy to
bike to school in the morning and that's
when I was in college actually what's up
do this is be from Tampa Florida
what's up B thanks for calling in man
down there in 10 mm down there in Tampa
and tamp is a great place to you know to
get a lot of they have Spanish moss and
also honestly to get pretty much
molested or kidnapped but you know it's
pirates country and things are gonna
happen everybody asks like Oh Florida so
crazy it's [ __ ] Pirates live there and
the grandchildren of pirates pirates who
died and still have gold in them and
still are on boats what are you gonna do
when you die probably [ __ ] nothing
okay probably just have your
grandparents show up at a church
somewhere and cry but pirates still sit
on ships and still scare people so the
fact that that vitter all that's in them
let that [ __ ] you know that spunk and
have them have one I so give them a
break man give people in Florida a break
these are the children and grandchildren
of pirates onward I'm calling in because
I'm a pretty regular listener of the
podcast you're funny dude and thanks man
I'm happy to be here with you [ __ ] dude
I'm I am just long day more I was just
curious if it bothers you or it's just
everybody calling in kind of talking
about drugs and stuff when you're sober
and you know I'm just curious as a guy
who's in and out of sobriety I don't
care and I still associate myself with
some of those people
does it ever kind of bother you that you
know your name gets thrown around in
here with like drug using a software to
make you happy because people get help
you know because when I was in rehab I
listened to you for a bit and they
helped me out well thanks for calling
man I appreciate that you know I mean
one thing about a program is you know
you're not supposed to use it to have
any you know any monetary gain or
anything like that and that's fine you
know I don't have any intention of that
um excuse me what I but also like I just
you know I I can't tell what tell people
what's going on sometimes in my life if
I don't tell them about that part
you know and I don't know if I'll always
be in a a so I'm not trying to be you
know uh I'm not trying to be like a you
know a role model or anything like that
um but it did that should save my life I
think and she hears
gave me perspective and my perspective
is still don't edit my perspective isn't
clear but it gave me a glimpse that I
was seeing the world wrong and that the
world was so much more comfortable than
I thought it was that the world wanted
me here so much more than I thought it
did that I had the ability to be of
service in the world more than I thought
I could that I that I was okay
you know I remember having it the first
day even a moment of thought that man
I'm okay and that's all it wasn't just
popped in my head I'm okay and it was
real as a feeling I'm okay
and to realize it you never have had
that it's like getting hit by a missile
and blowing up but not
but not moving or but but also nothing
happening at the exact same time it's
like getting hit by a reality missile it
just hits you and goes inside you and
blows the [ __ ] up but all the shrapnel
stays right in and all the shrapnel is
good and you're okay and the perspective
is Italy you see it you get a glimpse
like aw man I just didn't I didn't I was
I didn't have nobody taught me the math
right nobody taught me the math right
sometimes you teach you you teach
yourself your own emotional math as you
grow up and you got your own okay this
and this and and then that and you carry
that and then this feels like that and
that feels like that and this person
doesn't like and this person hates in
this and this is how I feel and that's
why and okay and it's always gonna be
like that in let's [ __ ] go I'll put
on some M&M you know or some dirty
Rihanna
you know some of that no D a sweet
sister Rihanna and I'll just keep this
chip on my back like I work for the
riedel's but that's not the truth and I
needed to see there wasn't my truth and
so then that's what started to happen
and so I don't feel like that I'm glad
that people you know if it gives them a
second to think about something to call
to talk about that kind of thing
I try to follow up with people that have
questions like that it helps me feel a
little bit of service sometimes because
there's a couple people that I talk to
now that I've met through the hotline
who are just part of my AAA Call list
that I'll reach out to sometimes and
what else does it make me feel bad
doesn't make me feel sad you know I feel
what makes me feel say it is if
you know if somebody hurts and there's
somebody like a young man out there and
I say young man a lot cuz that's what I
am you know and so I don't know you know
I don't know what it's like to be a
young woman and maybe it's not even that
different I don't know but I don't know
and if a you know if there's a young guy
that's hurt man that makes me feel bad
you know if there's somebody hurt and
they don't and they don't know any
better and they don't have a chance and
they think that somebody doesn't care
about them you know that hurts my
feelings dude so and I know there's not
much I can do about it and I guess it
hurts my feelings because I feel like a
lot of time that that was me you know if
like a lot of my life that that was me
and all I thought I
had was my hurt feelings you know and
all I thought I was ever gonna have and
I couldn't see you know I couldn't
always see my vision you know sometimes
it you have a you know you know your
vision of that porch where you got out
there with that lady new in that swing
and it squeaks a little bud and you keep
saying you're gonna fix it on that porch
swing but you're never gonna fix because
you like to squeak a little bit because
it's like an inside joke between you
guys but then sometimes that thing goes
away and it's just you in an apartment
and you're just thinking and that's what
your vision is it's you in an apartment
and you can't and you don't make them
you're not brave enough to make the
choices you're not brave enough to try
and get better or you never even know
that that you can be better or that you
could or that you are already better
that you are okay and you and then you
get this different vision and that
becomes more of a reality you know I
just I don't know I don't know man but
I'll tell you this so when I joke around
people about drugs and alcohol and I
joke about it with friends that [ __ ]
it's almost like using it I get the same
high I get the high of having fun with
friends and and that's all I really
wanted in the first place the only
reason I was drinking and using or
partying because I want to have fun with
friends and then it escalated where I
just was having no fun by myself kinda
but that's all I wanted was to have fun
with friends so now if I can fap I have
a group of people I can joke and [ __ ]
deal we'll talk about how [ __ ] up we
were my buddy got a blow job at a dang
from a professional tennis player and
fell through a skylight on his own
restaurant imagine that right into the
cooks dude come out honest you know
right the dishwasher was like [ __ ] I
gotta wash this a bloody [ __ ] seat
CEO but yeah magic in a blow job from a
professional tennis player a female and
next thing you know you step over
afterwards oh oh that was
[Music]
you know command and uh and I'm not
saying that the dishwasher was also were
Latino I'm just saying that they were
listening to Latino music and it was
white guys in there and they spoke
Spanish so don't jump to conclusions but
yeah you know what it's a it's a unique
world and that's where I am right now
and so it doesn't depress me out you
know
I think it's brave when people calling
about stuff I think it's really really
brave
let's hear more onward I'm going up to
y'all gang gang baby boy let's hear it
all right Dave live in Las Vegas man I
wanna start a company and then I
practice the dark arts on a daily basis
real messed up I know I need to stop I
love hookers I don't know what it is man
okay you get you a construction worker
because you run a construction company
you like them hookers you like them hook
hooks man you like that fresh cat on
that line you like that fresh cat you
like catching that fresh cat on that
trout line on that 70 pound test you
know onward you know I spent about an
average about 1,500 the 2000 bucks will
beat this on hookers come on dang was we
making some real coin boy $1500 where
the hook at a hooks Mike a man well I
mean it if they're enjoying you're
enjoying it what's going on with it
though what's up with it all I do is get
my dick sucked at least twice today
what all right hate that man if somebody
sucked my dick twice a day dude I would
[ __ ] call the police bro honestly it
would just slow me down too much all the
time for all of that but let's hear more
don't know what still man give me some
advice I appreciate it gangbang it
sounds like they're you out there on
that GB hunt well look man here's the
thing it sounds like it's a comfortable
system for you if you're calling me it
sounds like a little bit of your voice
that you're kind of happy about it like
you kind of pumped you know you're
showing off and I'm not judging you I'm
not saying it's bad I'm just you know
I'm evaluating from where I'm at you
know and I don't think that that's a you
know if you get a little bit of
you know you get some you know a little
pump and you stomp from that and you in
your heart pump and your aortas flare
out you know you get them full balloons
and blood balloons inside of you because
you know you like that life is it the
risk here's when something's bad I feel
like this is my perception when when
it's when it starts to become something
you can't be without can you stop maybe
it's not bad
can you take a break it's not bad can
you quit then it doesn't have control
over you but if you can't then what's
going on then you might want to look
into something else
but look man if you're keeping it you
know you keeping these ladies in
business everything a comfortable
environment right now then more power to
you guys you know y'all suck twice a day
yeah you're constructing that you should
just build a whorehouse you know build a
whorehouse with a diving board and a
pool shaped like a big mouth dude and
just get erect and just dive right into
that thing with your damn alright let's
hear another call that came in on work
hey ciosest in philadelphia got a quick
question okay Tamra deal with a
all-you-can-eat Rain Man
I went to the body of the day me and my
ladies and I wasn't sure of which to
order one all you can eat was if we were
allowed to share them or without a
violation we're going to kicked out of
rehab so we order two and we didn't eat
enough but I wanted more to go and I
only had two left
look dude here's the thing if you got
that you know that Bonnie and Clyde type
lady you know if you got that little
daredevil bad [ __ ] and she don't mind
you know getting that one you know
$21.99 and one you know she got to sit
down pretend like she having any wings
even though she haven't I used to love
that [ __ ] there when you would split
some someone person we're getting you
just sit by him you don't think the
[ __ ] boss knew oh you're the weird
dude who just sits in a restaurant with
somebody and doesn't eat but also has
food and crumbs all over their shirt
you're busted man our mirror our mom
would take us to this pizza place they
had a buffet and they had all you could
get fresh olives on there they had
probably that like an olive or had three
types of Olives which was a lot I mean
this was in late 90s that was a lot of
olives you know and we would get one
plate and all walk and hold it at the
same time like that [ __ ] matter dude
four kids holding one plate like it's
like a Olympic torch trying to pretend
like since we all had our hand on it
that we got the deal that it was all you
could eat nothing shadier than that boy
that's growing ivory all right there you
hide man eating real fast you you like
you're like the James Bond of digestion
you know you Lou you wait real quick and
and look you know as soon as a manager
looks away or a phone call comes in you
[ __ ] you know you to you tooth down a
couple of hits or something gang so I
look man I think if you're gonna take it
here's the thing if you take it later to
a wing place first of all it's kind of
shady bro take your lady to a nicer
place where they got a little bit of
fish I'm saying about that big guy fans
dinner by your lady a fish dinner
cuz some ladies want a fist and what
that car they want that jaw full of carp
you know they want to you know they want
to fall asleep at night and have a
little bit of mercury in the back of her
tongue women like precious metals so
don't don't take your lady you know for
a damn couple of hot chicken wings she's
had two of them now her eyes are
watering her makeups running she looks
like a raccoon that got into a fight and
it was just starting to rain come on man
take your lady by her that fish dinner
by Abbey Abbey as you dinner you know
I'm saying carp [ __ ] scallop mollusk
sea mollusk ahi ahi get your lady what
she deserves dude something that used to
swim and be free got there buying that
[ __ ] a small a swing with some [ __ ]
mustard on it Kim and treat her right
give you by your lady something had a
hook in it because women like that fish
women like precious metals you know they
want jewelry gold diamonds or you know
shined up or coppers you know at least
with fish dinner woman falls asleep at
night a little bit of mercury in her and
on her tongue a little bit of that Merc
Merc taste in her mouth make sure at
least feel sometime in her subconscious
like somebody bought our piece of
jewelry so keep your lady off the wings
and buy Tamia JPS dinner know that thank
you for calling let's hear another call
yeah that's crazy that you say one of
your biggest regrets in life is not
joining the military that's my biggest
regret in life but you know I would join
now I'm still young I'm only 24 but I
messed my ankle up when I was 23 hiking
and had that surgery so now I can't but
it just makes me think you know what do
you think about that and how do you uh
what do you talk to yourself and what do
you say to yourself to make it you know
not a big deal thanks for calling young
man well for me it's just you know it
makes me feel like less of a man that I
didn't serve you know um it makes me
feel it's an inferior thing it may
reminds me that I wasted time it reminds
me there were three or four years of my
life six years where I was probably
[ __ ] around you know where I didn't
have any game plan so I was living in
fear or you know I was just a freighter
who the [ __ ] knows maybe I was just
having fun I mean I was also probably
just enjoying the freedoms that you know
a lot of people have have given me you
know people forget this [ __ ] about
America that oh like let's let I you
know this could what we have has been
heavily defended heavily defended we've
had a lot of wars and in you know four
or five hundred years 1492 I guess I
don't know and is that even real who
knows you know there's been a lot of
lives of going through this to uphold
this country people forget about all
that
you know and people like well you know
they took the land from the Indians yeah
well they did man what the [ __ ] they
were fighting over it yeah it was [ __ ]
up but that's what happened a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
happened over the years
the dinosaurs [ __ ] they they broke a
lot of ice and stuff walking on ice
whose fault it are they
climate haters are they ice killers who
knows you know it was a different time
it was cutthroat and it could get back
to that and so sometimes I guess the
thing is is that I feel in fear because
men defended our country and women
defended our country and look I don't
see a difference between the two who
ever wants to defend it it's just as
honorable to me so when I see somebody
defended it I'm grateful I think if you
served in the military your vote should
count for more I think that a hundred
percent not a hundred percent more maybe
one and a quarter but you know what I'm
saying cuz you [ __ ] put jazz on the
line it's just uh and it's not even
something I have to think about it
happens inside of me that I feel in
ingratiated I know when I see these
Independence Day parades and stuff and
Veterans Day parades go down the street
I tear up
that's something cuz I feel something
but I feel bad that I didn't I wish I
had and who knows what the future will
hold but what can I do outside of that I
can you know I've done a you know if
this is a small thing but I think I've
done seven tours military tours overseas
so you can do that what else you can be
supportive you know we can try to do
something for some single moms who are
military moms well we can look for some
of those when we bring them out to the
comedy shows on singing only single moms
nights and we just had a single mom the
other night in Oxnard and uh and I'm
gonna give her a call in a little while
and we'll put that out as a set as a
separate clip but I want to thank
everybody for that help help me make
that a reality but yeah how do I deal
with regret I guess
stuff that you are doing and you find a
way that inside of you justifies
somewhat making it up you know I have I
have a friend who struggle sometimes who
is in the military sometimes I will you
know sometimes I'll ask me for money and
sometimes I'll give him money and and
for some people I've met but we're just
you know that's not a cool that's not
you know you don't you know teach a man
to fish you know give a man a fit you
know that thing but but he you know to
me it's you know I have freedoms like I
don't know but how'd I do with the
regret I realize is there a way that I
can make an amends to the regret for
myself over time is there something I
can do you know can i donate can I go to
two events can I support can I serve
overseas gotta do something nice for a
military person's wife can I remember to
call military people on special holidays
or text them reach out say thank you you
know I treat my mother's husband he has
Alzheimer's and stuff like that and he
just rides around on the truck or my mom
without they're delivering papers so you
got mr. Charlie he was in the war you
know but I try and uh you know always
remember to tell have my mom tell him
you know thank him for his service
because it's something that is still
really important to him it's one of the
only things that he remembers is that he
was in the military so you know there's
some real power in that that it sticks
in a lot of men anyway let's take
another call man here we go hey Mike I'm
a dentist I lived in New York City and
I've been listening to you for about two
months now thanks for calling Mike
homeward I was just listening to your
last
I was the go pack go episode and at the
end of the episode you said you were
talking about how important it is and
how crazy it is to realize that you can
love yourself and I actually got chills
I got like physical chills in my body
after I look through that I was like
holy [ __ ]
thank you feel so honestly thank you
very much I'm everything about that a
lot of public holidays make you feel oh
thanks for calling me and you know it's
uh
you know it's something that other
people help me learn and I'm learning it
as I go you know it's scary you know
when I found myself in some fear you
know loving myself and trying to stay
out of fear you know realizing that I'm
on a path like that I'm on you know that
that our life is a plan you know trying
to just because if I can believe some of
those things and find find foots if I
can put my feet into those things and
try and stay in there comfortably then
it just is so much less stressful it's
such an easier way to live yeah but it's
like do I give my like my brain will
quickly accuse me of
in old behaviors and not remind me
sometimes of the work that I've done to
get away from some of those you know
you're bringing the dark artist it's
there you know like Dexter had that Dark
Passenger you know some you got master
split
you got a shredder and he's suddenly you
realize he's your uber driver and even
though you've got all these you've done
all this direction work and all this
topography and you've made all these
maps sometimes he shows up and says oh
this where we're going but yeah it's
it's too you know it's a battle man we
try and remember how do we remember how
do I remember that I love myself I try
and you know keep in touch with people
that it will remind me of that you know
and that's one thing is from Joe you
know being around Jordan Peter stuff
this [ __ ] is a war out here there is
something that happened I believe two
men in the past I don't know if it's 30
years or generation or two our fathers
generation and then now it's infla it's
some things happen up like there's
something where we're just the connect
there's some mist there's some
disconnect and there's something inside
of us it's like it's like I just want to
[ __ ] roar but I can't it's like I'm
not allowed to be loud anymore
I'm not elec you know I'm not allowed to
to to be and that's [ __ ] it's tough
and I think that's one of the reasons
why we struggle to love ourselves
because the ourselves that is innate
inside of us isn't getting out as much
and it's not being respected in the
world and they you know they're you know
there's these finger point is that one
rapist is every man you know or one bad
person is that you know it's it's just
it's and it's just hard and there's just
there's something going on where I don't
know if we didn't learn something from
our fathers or we you know or our
fathers didn't you know if their fathers
were away at war and they didn't learn
so I don't know but there's something
intense happening it feels like a lot of
times
and maybe that's one of the reasons why
we have a tough time like loving
ourselves because I don't know if we all
see our self-worth and and I say if we
and I just mean me
you know but but look I'm glad that you
feel that way and I'm glad you were
brave enough to call and say that and
you know I don't know I just want to
stay out of my own ego and try and um
and just try and keep you know and just
try and grow up I guess I don't know
what I want to do but sometimes I want
to be just a kid again you know
sometimes I don't want to doubt I want
to grow up at all I don't want anything
to change
sometimes it just life just happened so
fast that it just makes me just so
scared because I feel like I'm just not
doing it right and I'm not getting you
know I'm not getting it right and I'm
not you know I mean that was one thing
about being around miss Peterson is that
you do want to live in the light you
know you want to live a clean life you
know and that's one thing I want to do I
want to get ahead of any dishonest ease
that I have or any things that I'm just
you know sitting in my past and just
holding stagnant water I want to get rid
of those you know because then if I have
without those if I can be in the clear
and living in at least in a clear
completely clear world of conscious then
I can I think then it's probably a lot
easier to love yourself you know because
uh this Dark Passenger sometimes will
remind you quickly that you gotta you
know that you have dirty shoes in your
in your closet or you have [ __ ] um
you have bloody pants in your hamper or
you have uh you know you have even
though you ran the dishwasher and you
run it every night that you still have
some dirty silverware in the sink you
know anyway but thank you for calling
man I appreciate it
let's hear this we had the best in worst
caller this is our winner from last
month and you talked about go pack go
here we go
hey Theo boy cooter over here and I
don't know uh so I'm called you your
little uh for best weekend worst weekend
deal Saturday was my birthday sunday was
Father's Day so I have this this a lady
in my life you know I've known her for
about eight years we've been dating now
for six months on Sunday on Father's Day
with our six-month deal Saturday we'll
wake up she makes me breakfast open some
presents she got me like almost the
whole damn Packer stores the whole
[ __ ] store Wow I mean that's crazy to
have so much stuff that is green and
gold at the same time I mean how could
you even do without it let's hear more
about Green Bay Packers fans she got me
bunch of shirts hat cooler she got me a
Davante Adams Jersey hmm then we went
golfing you know so she's in her
brother's dude if she's having you wear
that Devante why y'all's doing sex
Blaine that's a gateway drug dude first
you got the Jersey on then you got the
cleats on then she making you wear a
dark condom you know I'm saying making
you put some you know you know smoking
Winston's afterwards and chilling then
she's got you driving a [ __ ] Buick
she's got you you know I mean it just
it's never gonna end dude and then she's
gonna leave you for a beautiful strong
black man so just be careful with that
part of it but it's very sweet of her
this does sound like a good weekend send
their golfing you got yeah get ready put
get the ball up there as you sit there
you go out get in there and then yell
out at the very animal this woman went
out bought herself a Packers shirt and
ended up having sex with me in the
Packers shirt and then yell out a very
end
don't pack go mmm did that don't don't
get much better than I've seen in a
Packers fan but she knows she knows I am
so don't get much better than that
Thanks feel well and that's our best
weekend right there that man his wife
his girl isn't even a Packer fan but she
you know got packed up and they shipped
each other to uh in a calm town in you
know straight-up Combe town and next
thing you know they are they are he's
the winner you know so we're gonna send
him a beautiful gift package you know
that has awesome this past weekend
paraphernalia and stuff and positive
stuff oh man let me tell you this that
you can hit the hotline to let us know
what your best weekend or worst weekend
whatever this past weekend was don't
tell us some [ __ ] from years ago I don't
care
nobody people don't care if it ain't
fresh boy wing serving that so it hit us
with that fresh mess and at the same
time just leave it on the voicemail nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three as always you can hit the hotline
and if you have any thoughts suggestions
comments you want to be involved you
have a question if you have a struggle
if you if you are dealing with something
you know and you think that we can and
you want to introduce it to our world
the number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and we listen
to every call and we'll have one one
contestant right here a new contestant
for this new month of July for best
weekend ever but
is our go pack go as our winner for last
month and we will will hit you up and
get the information from you here you go
video so I'm from Charlotte I know you
have the best thing worst weekend things
going on about two weeks ago relapsed
did heroin okay for about three years
wow man I'm sorry to hear that Wow Oh
three years and then to go out man I'm
sure that's you know I'm sure it
probably really scared you so I'm sorry
Eddie go through that man woke up in the
ER basically dead baby to me two shots
of narcan and about an hour later I
realized as I'm coming to that the cops
are taking mescaline for investigation
keeps my car gone a while it was about
$600 and it was gone damn did you see
two wolves fighting at a stoplight did
you call that in lost it all Hollis hear
it so I would say that that was the
worst weekend that I've had and a long
time and struggling with alcoholism
go ahead meetings every day and I'm good
for you man good for you dude I've been
to a meeting in like a week and I'm
actually getting a little bit spooked
about it so I'm I try to go tomorrow
morning before I leave to Shanghai let's
go
starting to get back on track now really
excited to come out see you and rally
and I'm actually going to be proposing
to my girlfriend about almost four years
now the night before the show so it goes
from the worst weekend a couple weeks
ago to possibly the best weekend of my
life hopefully we can get a minute to
chat after the show and I'll see you
there and gang gang gang man you know
it's a
in here there man is that you know that
you have you had that misstep in your
sobriety and that you are still moving
forward with with the things in your
life that you feel like we're bringing
you positivity and asking your girl to
marry you and moving homeward and that's
powerful man that's powerful and that
you know I would assume anyway a lot of
that is just that you get some of that a
a built into you and it builds it you
know and it's built into your system and
you're able to you get back on your
horse and stay and stay moving onward
and if that is the definition of onward
you know to have that relapse to have
that moment you know when you had you
probably had a vision of exactly what it
was gonna look like you know you
probably had you and your girl in that
porch you know you probably had your
swing you probably a little bit of music
maybe a puppy out there maybe two dogs
even [ __ ] off by the side of the
house and I'm saying a lot of rich
people they like watching all that [ __ ]
our homeowners you know that's why a lot
of them have two dogs I'm like you need
two dogs dude are you just watching them
[ __ ] at night but you know you might
have had that vision you know that
special that vision and the main you
know it can all especially after a night
of drugs or party can all disappear or
it can feel like it can but boy you
saddle back up you move them forward and
and I hope that I see you and your
fiancee in Raleigh North Carolina and
that's two weeks from now man that's
awesome and that's at a good night's
comedy and I hope that um that we can we
can definitely chat for a minute man
hopefully we can chat for even more but
if she does say yes make sure she wears
that ring and comes on out dude
I want to thank everybody who called in
man everything's just been so busy the
past week but I'm so grateful to sit
here and just be able to like just try
and think out loud and have people call
and we can all just think about some of
this [ __ ] together and oh we talked to
Jeff who had them breasts and we're
gonna put that call up too we were gonna
do a follow up we did a follow up with
him thank you for the suggestions but
the 29 year old virgin we'll do a follow
up with him
and that's where we are if you have any
thoughts or comments or constructive
criticisms about this week's episode get
involved in the conversation you know
like I don't have to be right about any
of this stuff but I do I'm always open
to be thinking different and hearing
different stuff you know but thank you
guys so much for the support thanks for
the people that came out in Oxnard thank
you to our YouTube followers we just got
to a hundred thousand a hundred thousand
human beings that subscribed to the
YouTube thank you so much I mean it's
crazy if you dude if I remember looking
at my YouTube I'd never even looked at
it in years and I had like 400 followers
I was like [ __ ] man and now we just you
know there's people we just have a
little crew and it's exciting you know
and I think I think that together we can
do some cool exciting stuff I want to
apologize to that you know to my boy
some of the Latino warriors that came
out there in Oxnard and I forgot the
strap you know supposed to bring the
title belt and I forgot it and I owe you
guys man so when you come to the Comedy
Store
I got you I want to thank the brothers
that came out and I'm not talking black
guys I'm talking about there was a
couple of hermanos I'm a couple of
actual human brothers DNA you know DNA
sidekicks [ __ ] you know twins but not
even actually twins in just different
years you know what I'm saying like
[ __ ] roommates if you want to call them
that but they you know but they didn't
live it there at the same time so who
came out and that's always good to see
I'll see you guys soon what can we
listen to on the way out oh I didn't
even tell you that this song is called
the devil is a woman and I don't really
believe that or do i what do we think
the devil is chaos is a woman that's
what Jordan Peterson said you know Joe
Rogan said he couldn't kill a lion he
doesn't think I think he could did I
seen a video of a man pushing a lion
down by like a water fountain but this
is by Bishop gun the devil is a woman if
you have friends in Shanghai send them
out I can't believe I'm going to China
Duke he
leave that think about China man ha I'm
gonna be thinking about it be goody
cells you probably deserve it
oh and while we're listening to the song
i'ma open this beautiful gift and I will
tag the maker of it down below
[Music]
will mr. Johnson news cuz it's not her
up close in the devil said ma'am if you
don't mind would you tune this guitar
for me [ __ ] [ __ ] is home and she
bogus ha
[Music]
is she late you
ah
[Music]
it's beautiful right there you see them
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's all somewhere down in Georgia
still she blames a pretty means little
it's true whoa believable you got that
feeling of gold she will never have miss
out you want
that's how no mama there we go right
here
[Music]
and this is by this is by mr. Nicolas
naka righto sent this in and we are
grateful to him for this beautiful
American flag and we gonna put this
thing up in the studio and that's how it
happens just like that thank you guys so
much for your support this week be good
to yourselves you know we just got to
keep thing about our porch you know and
think about what's on it get specific
with that [ __ ] you know this gets
specific with that thing
I think who's out there with us you know
we can do it but it's gonna take work
man
so also uh Jordan Peterson gave us a
discount code to his who to his course
and we're gonna put that below as well
so that uh you can get it I'm taking it
so it's um it's self authoring and it's
about it's kind of about that it's like
about knowing where you've been seeing
where you are and where you want to go
because if we you know there's it's so
much easier than we think you have to
have a map you have to have mapped you
don't just land on a on Plymouth Rock
but maybe actually you do I think
there's people just [ __ ] landed there
that's crazy
but still man thank you guys be good to
your sails you probably deserve it